hello and welcome back to deepmind the
podcast
this episode is all about how ai is
already having an impact on the world
around us
shall we begin
[Music]
uh excuse me what are you doing starting
without me
i'm the real hannah fry
i'm only trying to help i heard you were
unavailable to present this episode so i
offered to step in
unavailable i'll take it from here thank
you very much
that voice you just heard there it was
generated using wavenet
voice synthesis technology trained on
audio recordings of my voice
in this episode we're going to be taking
a look at some of the ways that
deepmind's technology is already being
used out in the real world
including how wavenet can recreate the
voices of people with vocal impairments
it was really touching to see his family
and him listen to the voice his family
cried
because it's something that's so
personal
how neural networks can help anticipate
natural disasters
it is important to know if there's going
to be a buildup of a catastrophic storm
that's going to create flooding
and how ai could even transform the game
of football
so a coach might say to the system what
will happen if i move fabinho from
defense to midfield
welcome to episode 7 of the deepmind
podcast
me myself and ai
let's go back to that snippet of audio
from the beginning of this episode
generated by wavenet the deepmind
podcast aficionados among you may
remember that wavenet doesn't just
generate speech
it can also compose music
and we used a little bit of it in our
first series
but when it comes to creating human
sounding voices wavenet has improved
considerably over the past few years the
motivation however has stayed the same
everything from reading documents out
loud for the visually impaired to making
your smart speaker sound more natural
here's how zachary gleicher a product
manager on deepmind's applied team put
it
text-to-speech research has been
happening for decades and everyone knows
that texas speech voices have
historically sounded pretty robotic a
classic texas speech voice is the
stephen hawking voice british people
describe its accent as american here he
is speaking on bbc radio 4's desert
island discs in 1999 but the americans
say it is scandinavian
it's not because
people want robotic voices it's because
it's an extremely challenging problem
humans have evolved to be able to
understand very subtle nuances in how
things are set and if there's one little
thing that sounds off then people are
like oh that sounds robotic like if we
were to create a
dog barking generator
people would be like oh my god that
sounds just like a dog and you wouldn't
be able to perceive
any of the differences because our
brains not trained to know what good dog
barking sounds like meanwhile your dog's
in the corner being like it's so fake
exactly
[Music]
before wavenet the general method for
generating speech was called
concatenative text-to-speech
you'd get someone in a recording studio
and you'd record hours and hours
trying to capture all the phonemes in
the alphabet so that you have a real
diverse recording set
in production you stitch together the
voice recordings so imagine you wanted
to say the cat sat on the mat
and you had a recording of someone
saying the word the and you had a
recording of someone saying cat you
could stitch those two words together
but the problem there is that the voice
is going to sound like that
instead of stitching different bits of
pre-recorded words and syllables
together
wavenet directly models the raw waveform
of the voice building up less than a
millisecond of audio at the time
first it will scan the text you give it
for abbreviations and convert them to
something that can be fed into the
speech generator
like changing
hwy 101 to highway 101
[Music]
the second step is to try and predict
the intonation of how something should
be said based on the text around it
the can be read as the the
the
depending on where in a sentence it
falls
each would sound wrong if it was used in
the wrong context
now the third and final part is the
acoustic modeling
acoustic modeling focuses on who it
sounds like
if i pretend to sound like my brother on
the phone it still sounds like me my
friend will be able to tell it's me if i
say a sentence with a different tone of
voice you still know it's my voice
back when deepmind launched wavenet in
2016 you needed about four hours worth
of audio samples from a person to model
how their voice sounds
but now you can do it with just a few
minutes worth of audio
one of the big breakthroughs was a
process called fine tuning which makes
it possible to co-train voices together
google has built an enormous data set
with professional voice actors reading
out the same text
the model learns from all of these
samples how particular words are
pronounced
each new voice that is added to the
database results in an improvement to
all of the other voices and all that's
then needed is a small sample of a new
voice to provide the finishing touches
if you like that make the voice unique
to that person
that's why we call it fine tuning
because it's a way to just kind of
fine-tune the model based off that one
additional speaker because the
difference between your voice and my
voice for instance even though you're
speaking a different accent as a male
voice actually the way that we roll from
one word to another will have lots of
similarities yeah of course
after getting the all-important consent
from the person whose voice you're
creating it's as simple as recording
around 10 minutes of high quality audio
and matching those up with written
transcripts for the model to be trained
on
given that you had high fidelity good
recordings of yourself because you are a
podcast creator we were able to do that
without having to send you back into the
recording studio i had a hannah fry
voice bot where i could type anything
the power the power
hi there i'm a mathematician author and
podcaster who's fascinated by artificial
intelligence and i'm the real doctor
hannah fry
it's really good i know it's good what's
really awkward is that it's picked up on
a couple of the indonesians that i know
i must make but i've never really
noticed that i'd make yeah like did you
hear it went fascinating
[Laughter]
i love it see it knows you better than
you know yourself oh it's so cringe god
do i sound like that there were two
words that i thought sounded a bit off
one was mathematician
there was like a very hard bit in the
middle which i think isn't how i would
say the word i'm a mathematician author
and podcaster and i'm the real doctor
hannah fry
the second thing was how i said my name
it's a bit like you know when someone
reads your phone number back to you but
rather than saying like oh seven eight
one three they're like oh seven eight
one three video and then you're like
yeah there's something's gone wrong in
my mind yeah yeah if you synthesize long
sentences you'll notice there are some
things where you'll be like oh that
sounded a little weird texas speech
isn't solved yet we've reached the point
where voices sound perfectly natural in
many instances
and the challenge now is largely about
how natural it is given a certain
context
so for example if i wanted to text a
speech system that would
say
oh hannah i really like your sweater
now you say say it sarcastically hannah
wait oh
that's where we're really lacking is
like how do you capture everything
when i'm not trying to crack one of the
unsolved millennium prize problems you
can find me chillaxing with a cup of tea
and that quintessentially british tea
time snack a scone
am i that breathy bloody hell
sound like i'm on a sex line
the other thing that's worth saying
actually about that the way i'm having a
conversation with you now where i'm a
little bit more up and down and a bit
more energetic say
is a different sort of voice the audio
that this was trained on was the script
that i read out for series one so
inevitably then it will end up being in
that style exactly people will be like
make the voice sound happier make the
voice sound sadder and that's really
hard if you don't have examples because
the model has to learn what happy hannah
sounds like eventually though could you
have a system where the ai understands
how a happy voice differs from one
that's reading a podcast script
and can make those changes appropriately
yeah you can make hannah sound generally
happier but for people who know you
really well it's just like wait it
sounds slightly off because you might
have certain quirks about your voice
that can only be learned if you hear how
you say something you know if you always
elongate a certain word when you're
happy
as people do just so happy yeah yeah i
don't know if that's how you say things
when you're excited fabulous
i don't know everyone has their quirks
this next recording hints at how this
could be used dangerously you could
use the text-to-speech synthesizer to
say anything
hello i'm dr hannah frye and i'm here to
tell you that ufos are real when i went
into my garden yesterday i noticed these
strange dark circles on my lawn
how can you make sure that it's not used
for nefarious purposes
we thought a lot about this technology
on how it could be abused i think like
the thing that we care most about
is that people's voices are not created
without their consent
that's why we have not open sourced the
models we haven't made the data sets
available to mitigate a lot of those
risks but also there's a lot of cool
mitigations i think one that excites me
is that you need a script to be able to
create a voice
and
you could have that script be
you saying that i give consent for my
voice to be created
there is some research that's being done
that watermarks audio
is the idea that in creating this
artificial voice
you deliberately imprint tiny audio
signatures that you could see with a
certain piece of software perhaps but
that are
inaudible to the human ear so then you
can go in and say ah look this one is
fake exactly but here's the thing
watermarks could be removed people
might not consider that it's fake and
there are a lot of companies who are
releasing this technology it's not like
deepmind has the secret sauce there's no
surefire silver bullet way to stop this
technology being used by harm there's
ways to mitigate it but the same way
that we don't trust photos today
everyone sees a photo and be like is
that photoshopped i think it's going to
be the same with audio for better for
worst i think people are going to just
not trust what people are saying within
an audio recording and it's unfortunate
to see people
using it irresponsibly
because it might spoil a lot of use
cases that are really helpful for
society
zachary told me about a partnership
between deepmind and google called
project euphonia in which wavenet
technology was used to recreate the
voice of tim shaw
an american footballer who is diagnosed
in 2013 with als a progressive
neurological disease that causes speech
impairment
tim was a particularly good candidate
for wavenet
a lot of people who get diagnosed with
als are asked to do some voice banking
where they'll record themselves so that
they can replay their voice in the
future like if there's a song that they
love to sing but not everyone does that
and with tim shaw he had a lot of
recordings of himself because he was
interviewed on tv
it's that amazing pre-game electricity
the butterflies are there and i'm ready
to hit somebody so you might want to
look out
researchers use 30 minutes of recordings
to create tim shaw's synthesized voice
unfortunately when tim sat down with his
family to hear his own voice for the
first time in years
he struggled to recognize it i know you
remember that
it had
[Music]
if you hear an old recording of yourself
when you were a kid
you're like did i sound like that but
other people do remember how your voice
sounded his family did i want to explain
to you why it's so difficult for me to
speak the diagnosis all of it it's his
voice that i've forgotten
his family cried because it's something
that's so personal it's such a key part
of your identity
there is still more work to be done to
make this technology more widely
accessible to als patients it's tricky
at the moment because the augmentative
communication devices that people like
professor stephen hawking used to speak
are generally not connected to the
internet and unfortunately these models
are far too large to be run locally on a
device so you must be able to quickly
send data through to a server to get
them to work that's a work stream that
definitely is being invested in and i
think in time these people will be able
to have these voices on their device so
that they can use to communicate every
day
[Music]
while speech synthesis is a very
personal way in which ai is beginning to
touch some people's lives there are
other projects concerned with something
that affects all of us
whether we like it or not
the weather
deepmind has recently teamed up with
researchers at the met office the uk's
national forecasting service perhaps
when people think of the uk met office
they think of michael fish this
meteorologist who famously predicted no
storm back before i was born this is dr
neil robinson from the met office neil
he is talking about an infamous case of
a weather forecaster who in 1987 assured
viewers that there was no hurricane on
the way good afternoon to earlier on
today apparently a woman rang the bbc
and said she heard that there was a
hurricane on the way well if you're
watching don't worry there isn't but
having said that actually
the great storm as it came to be known
turned out to be the worst storm to hit
southeast england in three centuries
nowadays of course weather forecasting
is based on phenomenally sophisticated
mathematical models that churn through
eye-watering amounts of data
we have one of the world's most powerful
supercomputers for analyzing the physics
of what's going on in the atmosphere to
make our weather forecasts
the halls where those supercomputers
exist their football pitch size
but these models do have their
limitations
so traditional weather forecasting
approaches have a real sweet spot about
a couple of hours in the future to maybe
a few days in the future
but a lot of decisions need to be made
on a shorter time scale than that
this shorter term weather forecasting is
known
as now casting
now casting is the problem of predicting
where is it going to rain and how much
just a short window into the future
this is the voice of deep ryan hadsell
so we're talking just is it going to
rain over my house in the next 30
minutes up to a couple of hours into the
future and predicting at a pretty high
resolution where is it going to rain
what are the real benefits of being able
to know what's going to happen in the
next hour the dream here is to be able
to warn people before really extreme
flooding events so that they can take
action like evacuation
there's been a few notable examples over
the last few years of these really
extreme rain events in the uk the
flooding at boss castle and coverage in
the south west it is these pictures now
with the vehicles bobbing around in them
just just floating along like corks
which
actually under climate change one of the
things that we're reasonably confident
is going to happen more in the future is
the rainfall is going to become more
extreme
the problem here is that the traditional
physics-based forecasting models involve
so much number crunching inside that
football stadium-sized supercomputer
that by the time their forecast is ready
it's already out of date
so researchers use other statistical
methods for their short-term forecasts
including a technique called optical
flow a computer vision method developed
in the 1940s which tracks the movement
of air over a two-dimensional image
it looks at the current state of clouds
and precipitation and then it tries to
follow those streamlines to kind of
extrapolate where it thinks those clouds
are going to go in the future it's not
an unreasonable place to start but it's
quite a sort of first order
approximation of the problem
and then one day raya hadzel was at a
chance meeting in exeter chatting to
some people from the met office
when she realized that this description
of clouds moving in a particular
direction across a screen
rang a bell
it was startlingly similar to a well
trodden problem in deep learning
video prediction is an area of research
where you take a video and then you just
try to predict what the next few frames
in that video are going to be
so if i see somebody
swinging a cricket bat
and then you stop that for a moment i
can sort of say ah what's going to
happen next is that that cricket bat is
going to continue to swing through
and you can think about rainfall as
being a video that's playing over time
where the radar provides this
information layer over a map of say the
uk as the rain moves along maybe a storm
comes up or a storm dissipates and so we
thought that doing that short-term
prediction into the future could be
solved by using video prediction neural
networks
but before the neural network could be
used to predict precipitation it needed
to be trained
for that the met office had their
rainfall radar a set of instruments
which use electromagnetic pulses to
measure the location and intensity of
rainfall
we got about a year's worth of radar
data across the uk
and turned this into something that
looked like a movie like a video playing
and we started training different types
of architectures to just predict the
next few frames of video
and this worked all right but what
tended to happen is that the neural
network just predicted a blurred out
future so we started looking at other
methods to solve this
and the method that has worked extremely
well
is to use a generative adversarial
network
this is usually talked about more in the
context of deep fakes because this is a
method that can be used to produce
extremely realistic fake videos
and this has been a really worrisome
actually use of ai technology
and so it was actually really nice to
see that this was an application of gans
a gan or generative adversarial network
is a clever way of having two neural
networks compete with each other to
produce the most realistic images
it's as though you have a pairing of a
counterfeiter and a police officer
the counterfeiter tries to produce an
image that will fool the police officer
and if it's not good enough they'll get
caught and have to try again
over time that competition gradually
increases the accuracy of those images
in this case those images are
predictions of weather in the near
future
and using this technique the results
were startling
instead of producing blurred out fields
of rain it produced very crisp lines of
rain and realistic movements of storms
across the uk
to test out exactly how good this ai now
casting was compared to the optical flow
method
researchers fed in a radar image of
precipitation patterns over scotland and
asked the neural network to generate
predictions of what the rain pattern
would look like
over the next 90 minutes
they compared these predictions to
observations of how the actual weather
turned out
when i first saw these images it was
unclear to me which ones were the
observations and which ones were the
predictions
i said
are these the same images they were so
close it was remarkable what you thought
someone had got mixed up and just given
you the same picture twice they looked
very similar
it wasn't perfect but it was very
realistic
the structure of these clouds ends up
being an important predictor of exactly
how heavy rainfall will be
where and when
and once that precipitation hits the
ground a different type of model takes
over
working out how water will run downhills
and collect in valleys potentially
causing flooding
one of the advantages of an outcasting
system like this is that it could mean
that the output is more useful for those
flooding models because
the actual predictions that make have
this more accurate fine structure which
means that when it goes into a flooding
model it hopefully could lead on to more
accurate flooding predictions
we're not necessarily quite there yet
with this system but it certainly has
moved us another step along
the gan model doesn't just provide one
prediction it can provide many different
estimates of what's going to happen in
the future
[Music]
and by inspecting those different
possibilities we can get an
understanding of what the different
extremes of the scenarios are which is
really valuable when we're trying to
help people make balanced decisions
about what they're going to do
the people who need to make the
decisions are met office meteorologists
they are the ones who assess all of the
information available and construct the
final forecast
neil surveyed them to find out whether
they preferred using the ai tool to
traditional methods
they really regularly chose this new
deep learning methodology over the
traditional methodology which is a
really good sign
the now casting project represents a
first step in how ai could be used in
weather forecasting
but there are still important challenges
to iron out for instance because these
machine learning models are based on
what has gone before
they're not good at forecasting really
unusual extreme weather events
as forecasters the more rare an event is
the more interested we are in
forecasting it and that's one of the
great things about the traditional way
we do weather forecasting i think it's
also why in the view of meteorologist
deep learning is never going to replace
the physics-based models
i actually think the future is really
for a hybrid approach where we're able
to take the physical knowledge and
combine that with the
power of deep learning methodologies
because of these limitations and the
fact that neural networks cannot explain
all of their predictions in detail they
aren't yet being incorporated into the
met office's official forecasts but the
collaboration with deepmind has provided
a glimpse of a future in which
artificial intelligence technologies
augment the capabilities of trained
meteorologists
[Music]
of course being able to make predictions
is useful for all kinds of real world
problems
but how does ai fare in a game that has
adored around the world
for its glorious unpredictability
last year deepmind published a paper on
how ai could transform football in
collaboration with liverpool football
club here in the uk
why liverpool you ask
well who's your favorite football team
liverpool i love liverpool i watch every
one of their matches
turns out that deepmind ceo derma
cesarebes is a lifelong fan of the reds
now who would have thought it
i know no one will believe this but they
approached us of course we jumped at the
chance and they happen to have one of
the best analytics teams in the world of
sport currently and of course we got a
tour of the training ground which we
needed obviously to have as part of the
collaboration were you free that day i
was happen to be free that day
miraculously
of course crunching data to analyze a
game like football is nothing new
what has changed in recent years though
is the sheer amount of data available
everything from computer vision
algorithms monitoring players positions
and motion sensors picking up on players
movements
carl turles one of the authors on the
football paper is based at deepmind's
paris office
over the next five years one of the big
ambitions of this football work is to
build a prototype of an ai system known
as an automated video assistant coach or
avac for short
[Music]
this is basically a system that
seamlessly integrates several data
modalities like raw video footage
tracking data event stream data all
sorts of sensors that the players are
wearing to assist coaches with their
decision making
there are a few different techniques
that are useful here there's computer
vision which can detect what's going on
in footage from a football game
then there's game theory which is all
about maximizing your advantage over an
opponent
and then there are statistical learning
methods which can hunt for patterns in
previous games
put them together and this automated
coach could make counter factual
predictions of what would happen in the
game if a particular tactical change is
made or a certain player is replaced
say for argument's sake that liverpool
fc are up against arch rivals manchester
city in a big premier league game
liverpool's coach could use the ai
system to monitor the match and provide
tactical feedback in real time
so a coach might say to the system hey
avac what will happen if i
move sella from
winning a position to a striker position
or we would move fabinho from defense to
midfield
so sort of this counterfactual
questions that are really interesting
for a football coach can we play that
out based on what we've seen in the
first half
the coach could then be shown a
simplified simulation a video with dots
moving across the pitch to indicate
possible player trajectories in
different scenarios
the idea here is not to replace human
analysts but to complement them with
another powerful analytical tool
the avac
is just going to give advice
and is going to say like what it
believes is maybe a good action to take
and in the end it's up to the coach and
it's of course also still up to the
players to act upon that
[Music]
it's not just during a game that such a
system could be useful it could help in
post-match training too highlighting the
exact moment when it would have been
better for a player to pass rather than
taking a shot at goal
although deepmind's research is
currently focused on new analytics tools
for coaches and teams
karl tells believes there are also ways
in which ai could enhance the experience
of football fans
currently when a fan watches a game on
tv there will be like
expert commentary but with new
technology this could become
personalized expert depending on your
own interests maybe what sort of
questions you would ask the ai about
your game for example on tactics
maybe in a more distant future fans will
have access to a screen in the stadium
or vr that augments their experience so
for example getting a feel for the pitch
[Music]
it's easy to see how a more personalized
experience for fans and improved
predictions for teams could have an
impact on football in future
but as i said before football is a
joyously unpredictable game
i don't think we will be able to predict
outcomes of a game accurately at any
point in time and this simply because
the decision making of pitch by coaches
and on pitch by the players is still in
hands of humans right so the signal is
still noisy
and there are problems with relying too
much on ai for what is at heart a deeply
human game
in 2020 the scottish football team
inverness caledonian thistle fc
announced that it would live stream its
games via cameras which automatically
track the football to give viewers the
best view of the action
during one game the automatic camera
seemed much more interested in following
the linesman around the pitch
turned out it had mistaken the
linesman's bald head for a football
and there are concerns that computer
vision systems like these might be much
better at tracking some players than
others
the current systems don't capture the
events that happen in women's sports as
well as they do for men's sports
here's jackson brochier another author
on the football paper so even where
we're trying to do proactive research on
women's data in an equal way to men's
data the labels that identify what's
happening in the videos that we use for
the training are actually much less
accurate
to those clued up about the problem of
bias in ai this might sound like a
familiar story in order to get really
good at analyzing the performance of
football players and teams an ai system
would need to watch hundreds of hours of
video footage from football matches
all of this data then needs to be
manually annotated to tell the system
what is going on in each frame
the trouble is when it comes to women's
football there is not nearly as much
annotated data to train on you might be
wondering why would the gender of a
football player even be relevant here
but as we've seen in numerous other ai
systems sometimes even small differences
perhaps the body frame of the players
could be enough to mean that the ai's
predictions on those games would end up
being less accurate
there is a broader point here currently
ai systems are only as good as the data
they're trained on which means if a
particular group is missing from your
data set the implications can be huge
when they first released phones that
would unlock from your face the images
they used to train those algorithms
if they were more people of white skin
versus black skin then it learned how to
identify those faces better
what we want to do on sports side is
make sure that the solutions that we're
developing are not biased to
gender or
skin tone or any other variances in the
volume of data that we're learning from
researchers are currently considering
technical solutions to address the lack
of data from women's football
but these are specific fixes to a much
larger problem of bias in ai systems and
as much as those working here believe
firmly in the benefits of deploying ai
in the real world there are also
potentially unwelcome consequences
to new technologies that have to be
carefully navigated
in the next episode of the deepmind
podcast we'll be taking a closer look at
the efforts at deepmind to make sure
that when ai reaches the real world it
works for everyone
we know that periods of history have
caused harms to specific communities
right and if we look at modern
technology through that lens we see very
similar patterns and certain uses of ai
and that is all for this episode gotta
run because the forecast says reigns on
the way i'll leave the credits to my
wavenet voice shall i
deepmind the podcast is presented by
hannah fry
special thanks for this episode go to
norman casa grande the engineer at
deepmind who found the time to create
hannah's wavenet voice
the series producer is dan hardoon of
whistle down productions
until next time goodbye
you